here are our sources for our
myth-busting video about Barack Obama a
net spending cut candidate Obama stated
that he would enact a net spending cut
many times throughout the 2008 campaign
this example is from the third and final
presidential debate which took place on
October 15 2008 upon taking office
President Obama pushed through his
stimulus bill which immediately
increased government spending in
absolute terms already we're on track to
meet our goal of cutting our deficit in
half by 2013 forget about deficits in
2013 the government hasn't approved a
budget for this fiscal year yet even
though we're more than two months into
fiscal year 2011 the president's own
budget projections based on the rosiest
scenario as possible do show a decline
in the 2013 deficit and a steep Klein
immediately after that for the
foreseeable future if you like your
doctor or health care plan you can keep
it the point of Obamacare is precisely
to force all plans to do certain things
they're not already doing some versions
of the legislation include grandfather
clauses that will allow people to
continue with non-conforming plans but
it eventually phases them out and up to
3 million seniors will likely be forced
to change their Medicare prescription
drug plans whether they like them or not
American taxpayers are now positioned to
recover more than my administration
invested in GM for all the ballyhoos
surrounding the initial public offering
of stock from GM the plain fact was that
the Treasury Department lost 4.4 billion
dollars on the stock sale or more than
ten dollars per share that sold at $33
the remaining 500 million shares will
need to be sold at $53 a share for the
government taxpayers to break even and
that's a number few analysts believe is
likely we just had a tough election we
will have another in 2012 as President
Obama has acknowledged he and his party
took a real show lacking in the midterm
elections precisely because Democratic
policies were unpopular with voters but
2012 is a long time in the political
future if Obama learns from Bill Clinton
and moves to the center he might be
sitting pretty in the next
if he serves up more of what we've seen
in the past two years well it was nice
knowing him for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
you